el clamor antivacunas se encaminó hacia
parís
cientos de personas transitan por
francia en lo que llaman el convoy de la
libertad emulando el movimiento de
protesta de los camioneros canadienses
que inició hace dos semanas pretenden
que los gobiernos desistan de los pases
vacunales saval boards hágale bolt
geniales como map estamos hartos de
todos la gente está harta nosotros
estamos hartos de todas las decisiones
que se toman sin tener la cabeza clara
que se toman sin ni siquiera consultar
la opinión de nadie se pierde la
seguridad de parís fue redoblada para
prevenir actos violentos como los que
protagonizaron los chalecos amarillos en
los años 2018 y 2019
mientras la gente circule no hay
problema pero la manifestación no es
posible y parar en medio de la carretera
está prohibido por el código de
circulación y está sujeto a sanciones
muy duras las autoridades capitalinas se
recordaron que el bloqueo del tráfico
puede conllevar multas de hasta dos años
de prisión cuatro mil quinientos euros y
la suspensión de la licencia de conducir
kremen bound secretario de estado de
asuntos europeos
probó la actitud de los manifestantes
no es el convoy de la libertad es el de
la vergüenza no son patriotas son
irresponsables y aunque parís puede ser
la próxima parada para este movimiento
antivacunas el destino final sería
bruselas donde pretenden también
manifestarse